>> ♪ ♪
>> Shannon: TONIGHT WE EXPLORE
THE TOPIC OF TRANSGENDER
ATHLETES IN HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS.
IT'S A DIFFICULT BALANCE TO
COMPETE ON AN EQUAL PLAYING
FIELD.
HERE'S JACKIE.
>> HIGH SCHOOL RUNNERS ARE GOING
TOE TO TOE WITH THE NEW ENGLAND
REGIONAL CHAMPIONSHIPS IN
BOSTON.
A CHANCE TO GET IN FRONT OF
COLLEGE COACHES AND MAYBE EVEN
EARN A SCHOLARSHIP.
BUT CONNECTICUT JUNIOR SELENA
WON'T COMPETE.
SHE WAS ENGLAND OUT OF THE TOP 6
SPOTS IN PART BY 2 TRANSGENDER
RUNNERS.
BOTH MALE AT BIRTH.
NOW IDENTIFYING AS FEMALE.
>> IT'S FRUSTRATING AND
DEMORALIZING WHEN YOU ARE AT THE
START LINE OF A RACE WHEN YOU
KNOW WHAT THE OUTCOME OF THE
RACE IS BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
>> A MEDICAL TRANSGENDER RUNNER
SAID HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETES CAN
FACE UNFAIR COMPETITION FROM
TRANS-GIRLS.
IT COMES DOWN TO WHETHER THEY
HAVE GONE ON HORMONE THERAPY.
>> BEFORE THEY GET ON HORMONES
THEY HAVE THE ATHLETIC
CAPABILITIES OF MEN.
>> IT MAKES REGIONAL
COMPETITIONS A GRAY AREA.
CONNECTICUT ALLOWS TRANSGENDERS
ATHLETES TO COMPETE WITHOUT
RESTRICTIONS.
17 STATES REVIEW INDIVIDUALS AND
9 STATES REQUIRE SURGERY OR
HORMONE TREATMENTS.
PART OF THE CHALLENGE IS AGE.
COLLEGE STUDENTS MUST UNDERGO A
YEAR OF HORMONE THERAPY TO
COMPETE AS TRANS- ATHLETES.
CIVIL RIGHTS ARE ALSO A CONCERN.
ATHLETE ALLY IS A LGBTQ GROUP.
>> IF THEY SEPARATE THEM IT'S
NOT FAIR.
>> ADVOCATES SAY RULES FOR